pour le groupe Union centriste pour 6
minutes
mes chers
problèmes je vais évidemment pas
utiliser la totalité de mon temps de
parole
remercier Madame Gatel dont la
évidemment la perspicacité encore
frappée et plutôt dire que évidemment
notre groupe soutient ce texte puisqu'il
répond à un problème ponctuel que tout
le monde est d'accord nos collègues à
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement
donc vraiment aucune aucune espèce de
difficulté vous dire mais le ministre
comme c'est important d'avoir cette
délégation collectivités locales
tellement attentive même pour régler des
problèmes qui peuvent sembler
insignifiants sauf pour les gens qui
sont directement concernés parce que
c'est toujours c'est toujours évidemment
le cas donc moi je n'ai absolument rien
d'autre à ajouter sinon que il faut
évidemment écouter le Sénat et que le
principe des niches parlementaires et
d'autant plus importante qu'il peut
porter évidemment des solutions pour
pour ceux qui en ont besoin je vous
remercie de votre attention
très bien très bien chaque collègue la
parole est maintenant madame